the Joe Rogan experience yeah but the
biggest name was the Burmese guys you
know they're like fifty five million
people if four people I don't know that
there's 55 min people in Myanmar and
their natural support islets way yeah
and it's like your religion that is
crazy crazy it's crazy that it's so
popular there and most people unless
you're hardcore martial arts fan you
don't even know about it yeah there's a
lot of UFC fans probably listening to
this podcast just hearing about let's
wait for the first time yeah and it's
it's okay because I had like again gyms
that hosted a seminar with me and he
said he's a marshal at it for 40 years
and never heard of it literally Wow so
it's okay we're in that transition now
you know but then in 20 30 years where
they're gonna ask hey do you know about
Latoya yeah I heard the podcast well
it's also YouTube I think a lot of the
videos of your fights and some other
fights on YouTube people go whoa they
see the head butts and the body slams
and the suplexes and [ __ ] it just shows
like wow this is why all this is a wild
sport it's pretty excited one of the
rounds of a normal length three five
rounds of three minutes yeah okay yeah
exactly very similar to more time yes
but then the crazy part which my fights
I've fought in the traditional literal
rules is that you have an injury tab
mount and injuries are meaning that
let's say you knock me out Joe and then
I have the they pull me out of my ring
in my corner they slap my face they bite
my ear they pull right here here
whatever do you want to make me up they
light your ear but that helps you wake
you up really I don't know hurts no it
we have they done that not to me guy
never used but you've seen people do
that I pull the hair yeah you've seen
them bite each other's ear just like the
mumbled images she won the ear a little
bit really it hurts not oh well I'm sure
it hurts but I mean what about ice so it
seems like that'd be a better way to win
you everything because let's say you
have two minutes to get revived okay so
you get ko'd yeah and the fights not
over two minutes to get revived why
isn't the fight over I don't know that's
there in traditional back to 2,000 years
ago these they want to give another
chance but the double you'll see I
thought oh my god they're so crazy yeah
WLC is eliminating the one with that and
I'm good with wrong guys to have a
career out of literally right yeah it's
better for the brain oh yeah a lot
better because I've seen I think only
seen one time actually it was two men
with I think Cyrus who actually
you get the only guy you know you get
knocked out he went back to his corner
got revived and won the fight what yeah
we win by decision and although this is
how the the Cyrus Washington's corner
threw in the time wow that's really rare
so most of the time when you use your
timeout your outlet you're gonna just
get knock out twice yeah I would imagine
I mean you just had a serious head
oh is that it right there yeah show it
show it to me in the beginning show it
to me in the beginning nice elegant
enough boom elbow here oh my god it's
out [ __ ] cold I look the dragged him
out and you actually finishing won the
fight that is the same so the dragon
that is [ __ ] insane that is [ __ ]
insane that thing they're gonna bite ear
soon oh they're not gonna bite yes don't
tell me they're gonna bite it's Little
Edie drag him he's out cold and this is
one of the strongest like like he was to
to man yeah so sit him down
he's literally uncanny way to stuff now
he's starting to wake up with the water
that's hard though like that's freaking
a heart like can think about what Jamie
they just bit his ear rewind was biting
his ear they pouring water on he's gonna
do it right there huh
anyway anyway just like yeah that's that
oh he tried to bite his ear it really
did that's right
so they just pouring water on them and
they give me a chance to wake up hey
wake up bro and he's that is so crazy
what kind of idea right there yeah oh my
god he's kissing them - he's making out
with us he's like oh I'm gonna [ __ ] you
if you don't wake up and the crowd goes
crazy because they like you know they
want him to keep going yeah it's like
it's really about grit and about like
heart and he goes back look after at
like 36 and he ends up winning
are they gambling they're here as well
I've not aware of it I think really but
a little bit it's not but it's not my
talent I know there's no alcohol service
it's about Latoya but it's not like
Thailand yeah
okay so here's Cyrus Washington they put
his mouthpiece in and he's aware of the
rules right he knows he knocked him out
yeah but then it's a long time after
that so how much time it's a long time
like how long I at the end of the fifth
round
but how many how much time they give
them a break way it's a minute or two a
breakthrough in between rounds
nobody I mean while he got knocked out
was it to revive him is that just just
two minutes yeah oh look at this he's
already back to it you know that is cold
that's crazy so this is so bad for you I
find I fought both of them I fought
Cyrus and I fought to two min three
times so basically the look that is the
end so Cyrus just quit out yeah a towel
they're like it's over it's over so -
tell me what the [ __ ] that's crazy
[Applause]